[Musica]
[Applauso]
avete presente quella data quella data
dove inizia tutto quella data che vi ha
cambiato o vi cambierà la vita la mia f
ottobre del 2011
otto anni fa io ero trasportata dietro
dal mio ragazzino dell'epoca in scooter
e abbiamo avuto un inizio niente
stradale è inutile dirvi come è finito
perché lo vediamo come il finito ma in
realtà per me essere qui oggi non è
affatto scontato
essere qui oggi è il tema di tante
piccole scelte quotidiane che ho fatto e
che mi hanno portata essere libera
felice e orgogliosa ma non vi nego che
tutto questo non è stato un percorso
facile anzi da quella data in poi ho
vissuto nove mesi in ospedale e vi posso
garantire che le serie tv sono molto più
simili alla vita reale di quanto non si
creda
immaginate di essere paralizzati nel
letto e avere come unica domanda unico
pensiero
caspita ma ora va a casa apre l'armadio
e scoprirà con solo perizomi è bene
sempre
oppure ancora di aver realizzato in quel
momento di aver fatto tanti anni di
sport e sacrifici per nulla perché
passerò la vita in carrozzina e nessuno
mi guarderà più il sedere fa male quando
lo realizzi oppure ancora di f braiati
nel letto in palestra e nel momento in
cui arrivano tutti gli studenti di
fisioterapia realizzare di non essere
neanche defilata
insomma chi ci perde che in questi
momenti uno capisca quali sono le cose
importanti
nella vita ma per me non è stato così di
volta è stato l'inizio di una vita che
io chiamo tragicomica perché i grandi
risate e domande che non hanno il sapore
dei miei 19 anni domande che li facevo
nel letto e domande senza risposta come
farò di nuovo felice troverò l'amore
reader o davvero come prima e poi c'è
lei la grande domanda che ti arriva vale
la pena vivere così
queste domande sono davvero senza
risposta e su domande che ti fai
paralizzato nel letto anche perché
quando stai paralizzato a letto
vi assicuro che non hai tanto altro da
fare che non alzare la testa a guardare
il soffitto e legge c sopra domande o
magari se molto molto fortunato arriva
un infermiere simpatico ti fa qualche
battuta e to ride ma le domande tornano
sempre
nove mesi sono davvero lunghi e questa
compagna di vita che sembra accanto a me
mi ha insegnato moltissimo ma
soprattutto mi ha insegnato cosa
significa la parola limite perché tutti
tutti abbiamo dei limiti quello che
forse la mia vita il mio limite per ha
sbattuto molto più chiaramente in faccia
io ogni mattino quasi più cosa voglia
fare qualsiasi sia il mio umore
se voglio muovermi devo prendere lei se
voglio muovermi devo prendere questa
carrozzina pensateci paradossale se
voglio muovermi devo prendere il mio
limite limita io vi assicuro che questa
parola lo lo patita per i primi anni
della mia nuova vita in carrozzina
questa parola ha rischiato di
determinare tutta la mia vita finché a
un certo punto non so bene cosa sia
successo credo che siano
la domanda che ti dicono hai toccato il
fondo
io questa cosa del fondo non solo mai
creduto diciamo che cos'è il fondo
finché ho realizzato di aver proprio
toccato il fondo ma in quel momento ho
anche realizzato che avevo uno strumento
per risalire ed era lei la carrozzina è
così nata una nuova domanda e ho deciso
di ribaltare la prospettiva mi son
chiesta finora è pensato tutto ciò che
non potevi più fare
ma tutto il resto è la verità che dietro
a queste piccole parole e tutto il resto
c'è la vita e cosi ho ribaltato la
prospettiva e ho deciso che il mio
limite non era tutto di me per una
piccola parte è che le mie braccia
potevano essere le mie gambe e cantare è
sulle spalle di mio marito
uno di quelli prudenti diviso per a via
si poteva fare e sapete
poco importa come arrivi in cima spesso
ridicole braccio con le gambe perché una
volta arrivato in cima
nessuno ti guarda dicendo ti è un limite
ma la gente ti guarda con gli occhi di
rispetto e di stima di chi ti dice ce
l'abbiamo fatta siamo qui insieme allora
io chiedo voi
ma che cos'è quel limite perché quel
limite non è tutto quel limite io ho
deciso di farlo diventare un dono ma io
nessun altro io ho deciso di guardare
con occhi nuovi questa carrozzina
io ho deciso di guardare con occhi nuovi
il mio limite io ho deciso di riprendere
in mano la mia vita è diretta e che c'è
va bene così mi piace così e insieme
faremo qualcosa e stiamo andremo oltre a
quello che c'è stato prefissato è
pazzesco parlare del proprio limite
della propria carrozzina come di un dono
o di un compagno di vita ma vi giuro è
quel che è
sapete qual è la strategia che ho
imparato per fare della mia vita
qualcosa di straordinario non lasciare a
nessuno il potere di decidere qual è il
tuo limite e qual è il tuo dono quando
decisi di andare a la paz in bolivia
la metropoli più alta del mondo
quattromila metri
dovete chiamare i medici per chiedergli
come dovresti gestire l'eparina è un
farmaco che che previene il rischio di
trombosi e loro mi dissero è una
giuliano non abbiamo una statistica e in
quel momento non sapevo se ridere o
piangere perché realizzai che la pazza
non era la metropoli più gettonata da in
turismo in carrozzina varani fi anche
che era la mia
e allora me la scelta o mi arrendo il
mio limite o vado oltre e chiaro quello
che fa sono andata oltre
sono andata lì
anche se vi garantisco che è arrivata in
sì ma ogni 10 minuti io mi contro il
napoli ma l'ha fatto
vedete perché credo che alla fine si
riduca tutto ad un'unica grande domanda
ad un'unica grande cosa a scegliere cosa
vogliamo fare della nostra vita
tutti abbiamo dei limiti e tutti
rischiamo di dipendere dai nostri limiti
alzi la mano chi almeno una volta nella
vita non si è sentito dire non sei
capace
alzi la mano chi almeno una volta nella
vita non si è sentito dire non fa per te
vita non studio dirà tu non puoi farlo
insomma ad un certo punto nella tua vita
a tutti iniziano a dirti quello che non
potrai più fare
e sono questi piccoli no che poi
diventano tu non puoi non va bene lo no
e alla fine
rischiamo di crederci finiamo tutti con
i rischiare di crederci e invece di
essere tutti i tuoi puoi rischiamo di
essere tutti i nostri non puoi ma io non
sono il mio limite
io sono molto di più e tu non sei il suo
limite
tu stai molto di più tu sei quello ultrà
anche quando quell'altro una montagna
alta 4000 metri lo sto fa ridere che io
faccio sempre paragone con le montagne
ma vedete quando ero piccola tanto tempo
fa
e mio padre mi insegnava a scalare mi
diceva sempre non guardare già la non
guardare già su non guardare la meta ma
guarda bene quella presa perché grazie
al peso di quella presa tu vai la presa
successiva è presa dopo prese arrivi
alla meta
dico questo perché mi vien da dire io
nella mia vita ho deciso di fare questa
scalata perché ogni obiettivo che mi
sono posta da queste ottobre a oggi era
più su e un passo da molto fatto quello
che ho voluto e un passo la volta ho
fatto quello chiamato
anche frey un pasto è rimasto per dire
ma vi giuro che è un posto alla volta mi
ha portato qui a dirvi oggi guardate in
faccia i vostri limiti accettateli
vogliategli bene perché saranno proprio
loro a farvi dare il cento per cento
nel restante delle cose della vita
quando hai un limite quando hai una
mancanza fai di tutto per farla essere
l'unica della tua vita rischiare di
rimanere allettata è quello che mi ha
spinto ad avere più sete di esplorare
più terra sta per un giorno di essere
una mamma che non andrà più in
bicicletta e quello che mi ha spinto ad
eccellere nell'imparare a giocare con i
bambini sapere di essere diversa
e quello che mi ha spinto divulgare la
ricchezza dell'inclusione nelle aziende
in questo senso il mio limite un dono
per chi ogni giorno lo guardo lo
riguardo in faccia guardandone e mi
ricorda che posso andare oltre
mi ricorda che possa eccellere quindi
guardate in faccia i vostri limiti vi
scoprirete come io vi sono scoperta e
non dite e non diciamo ci basta aversi
l'occasione di l'occasione non è domani
o dopodomani l'occasione ore oggi qui e
io sono qui per dirvi una frase che
avrei voluto sentirmi dire io otto anni
fa
sono qui per dirvi che è possibile che è
possibile dopo otto anni guardarsi
indietro dire ma la mia vita mi piace
perché io non sono quel limite
io sono quello oltre grazie
[Applauso]